Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer. The internet,
the card game is available right now. And the link in the bio,
or you can get a Barstool sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us. Let's get into it.
Hey, it's Abella danger. And I am back to answer the internet. Once.
Would you rather fight a hundred duck sized horses or one
horse sized duck? So like, yeah, no, I,
I couldn't do it. I'm picturing like a little horse.
Okay.
I once ran over a duck, so I once ran over a duck.
So, um, it was in the road. Um.
Um.
I'm, I'm, I'm more scared of ducks than I am of horses.
So I think I would rather fight a hundred duck sized horses.
But.
Because of their beaks. Cause it's like, and I ran them over.
So I feel like they all have like a vendetta against me.
They know I killed one before.
Would you watch a porn with the hottest girl from your high school?
If the dude and it was your dad? Yeah,
I would actually still hot. I wouldn't mind that she's,
my dad would be like props, dad. Like, yeah.
It's really hot. You know? It is. Yeah. Yeah.
This is girl.
She's actually like a little Instagram model and I've known her since like
middle school and he was Ms. Buscemi on Instagram. So she's thinking.
Yeah. Yeah. I went to middle school and high school with her.
Yeah, we're in the same high school together. Yeah.
If you were on an old episode of room raters, what would be the most,
what would you most be afraid of being found in my room.
I guess my list of like where I rank all the people I've had sex with.
And then I put a one to five star ranking.
Every person you've ever had sex with. Mostly every person. Yeah.
Even people with like before porn, I would like, I had like a list and then.
It's lengthy.
Um,
I guess I stopped like once I just kept having sex with the same people in porn.
So probably like 80 to a hundred people.
What is the one thing that someone can say that makes you immediately hate
them? I don't need us.
I love Trump. Um, I live with my mom,
um, I'm vegan. Um,
so many things. How much is too much for a high difference in a relationship?
Um, a lot of girls really like super tall,
but I like guys that are kind of like my height so that we could do the standing
sex because if they're too tall and you're like, the shower sex is harder.
So, um, I think like, listen.
[Inaudible].
No like shorter than a foot.
Like I guess like five 10 is good for a guy.
Would you rather sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've ever had or say by yourself to watch a sex tape of the night?
The concede you definitely sit by myself and watch the night.
They conceived me as disgusting as it may be.
I unfortunately had to like hear my parents have sex growing up sometimes.
Like I would stay up a little too late and I would hear something in the
distance and I was like, what's going on? But I, I, they would be traumatized.
They witnessed every single sexual encounter.
So I'll take one for the team and I'm holiness. So honestly probably boring.
My, my dad looks like a two punch jump.
I'll just.
Say, what would you give up first? Drinking, watching sports or coming?
I would give up drinking. Drinking is but forever. Yeah,
I would go drinking. It's fine. It's fine.
I would never give them coming. I'm sorry, like, I'm sorry.
It's like the best feeling in the world.
Like if you have to watch one category of porn for the rest of your life,
what would it be? Incessant and just kidding.
Um, it would definitely be, um, big wet bites.
That's what a very popular search term of mine and like
anime
and it can't pick just one. Um,
and yeah. And then milk cream pies for sure.
What I like, what I like,
what do you think is the oldest someone's been when they've had sex
in their nineties? Is that possible women for women, women can get,
but when did the guy's Dick stop working? But they can get a pump?
No.
Okay.
There's guys important that have the pumps and they like just like squeeze their
balls and it goes, whoop easiest ever.
So, but I guess with all the pumps or pills or anything 50,
I don't know. Those guys had sex was.
The oldest oldest man is 50 years old. That's what she said. Right?
That's what I'm saying. Without pills or like a pub or any help, like naturally.
Oh, he's so hot. Is he only 55? Isn't it like, he has to be old.
Excuse me older. Because like Brad, Pitt's like in his fifties now.
Oh. Those guys are not naturally.
No,
I think he's probably having to like take some biography or something because
even guys in porn that are like in their like forties,
if you're born with action finger, hands stuck in the same position,
what position would your hands be in?
They only want them to be like this and then they could, yeah.
We want them to see like this. Yeah. Like this. Cause then you could like,
for that, you could also like you did like why
you can do so much with it like this.
Yeah.
I dunno. That might get hard after a while, but what do you need to do?
Would you rather be falsely accused of murder or never be able to stop coming?
Never be able to start coming for sure.
I don't wanna be falsely accused of murdering. Wouldn't do good in jail,
but never you get out,
but some people get falsely accused end up getting.
It'd be fine in jail. No. Yeah.
I definitely become someone's. Like get a girlfriend, you know,
be her little bottom, but never starving coming.
That sounds like more fun than I would have a very strange life though.
Like how would I even walk? Yeah.
Like a restaurant. You could just be like around a kid one day.
You're coming all the time.
So, you know, I could do it. It would just be difficult.
If you could pick any character from TV or movie to be your college roommate,
who would it be? I guess it would have to be Fiona from shameless,
so high. And I love her character.
She's so slutty and I feel like we would have awesome sex and we would like go
out and like find boys and them together and just do crazy
to make happen. I with her.
Would you rather have a dog die every time you laugh or
have there be a genocide every time you fall in love?
Well, the world is pretty overpopulated, so,
and I'm not going to fall in love that often.
So I think I would rather have there be a genocide every time we fall in love.
[Inaudible] like what country?
[inaudible].
Definitely what's that country with. Is it,
I dunno if it's the North of the South Korea. North Korea. Yeah. I'd have them.
Yeah.
I think just one guy is the problem there.
A lot of people stand by him there.
So all the people that stand by him in our country can go, okay,
if your life depended on it,
what gymnastics event would you bet your life that you could do? Well,
I used to be a cheerleader so I could do lots of tumbling,
but I don't know what that's called in gymnastics because I just did it in
cheer. So yeah.
You do a tumble right now in this room.